welcome to the billionaire mindset your
30-day journey to
thinking like a billionaire now you can
just watch this video or if you want to
sign up for the entire series for free
and get the bonus pdf
companion calendar check the link in the
description below today is day eight and
we're going to learn the belief systems
of billionaires
enjoy
[Music]
when you're saying i know who i am and
i'm telling you it's the thread
that runs through everything it's the
thing that allows you to
stand in your own truth and one of the
things for
years that maya angelou used to say to
me is baby you need to know
that you alone are enough
you alone are enough
if you take a look at life you can have
your glasses they say half empty or half
full it's how you look at it
now i've been homeless twice when you
are down
first time was 22 years old and i had a
child
homeless with a kid you know he was a
couple years old which would be
interesting because most people see you
now in this multi-billion dollar
situation
they would never believe that at 22. you
were homeless with a kid
i mean it didn't look like the
trajectory was heading here right yeah
but when you're down and out and you're
that far
down and you've got a kid and you're
kicked out of your place because
rents do you don't have the money and
your wife took off with everything
everything yeah just little kids wow
anyways we were just too young to get
married uh
so you know how to make it now when
you're that low found a friend of mine
who's a blue singer said
when you get down so low and you look up
all you could see is an edge right
when you're that low you could only go
up true so instead of you have a choice
you could sit around and blame what
happened to you on
everybody else which is usually what
people do
or say hey that's how things turned out
now i'm going to turn things around
another very important thing when you're
down and out first thing people do
is blame it on everybody else but
themselves so true
when you start taking responsibility you
have a little different outlook
you also have the responsibility of
turning things around when i started
paul mitchell i was homeless once again
totally by accident and i i started the
company out of the back seat of my car
how old were you at that time 30 seconds
that was 34 35 at that time so you're
homeless at 34.35 again yeah
i visualized this for myself when i was
selling copiers door-to-door
i had a very clear vision of what my
life was going to be like
and i encourage everyone to do it take a
snap photo of what success looks like
for you
are you how many employees do you have
how much are you making where do you
live
what are you sitting at a table with
world leaders are you standing on a
stage in new york city giving a speech
and hold on to that that snapshot and
you will subconsciously start to make
decisions that get you there
and so my snap photo for myself when i
was going door-to-door to sell copiers
was to be self-employed invent a product
that i could sell to lots of people and
not just
one copier to each person and create a
business for myself that would continue
to
fund itself if i wasn't present i wanted
money to be generated without me having
to be there i was that specific
in my vision is it going to be a
business kind of tourism in
in orbit or is it more a kind of plan b
if things on earth do not develop as
well it's not exactly a plan b
it's it's more that i think i think
there's two two aspects to this
uh one is that we want to have a future
that is inspiring
and exciting and what are the things
that you find inspiring and exciting
about the future
i think one a future where we are a
space faring civilization
and out there among the stars i think
that's every kid gets excited about that
you don't even need to teach them
they just get it's like instinctive
and so we it's very important for us to
have reasons to
like reasons to be excited about life
like when you wake up in the morning it
can't just be about problems
it's okay i know everyone in this room
deals with a lot of tough problems
but you know it's got to be more than
that so
you know i think a future where you can
say hey even if it's not you
there's going to be people out there
they're going to we can have a base on
the moon
we're going to have a you know a city on
mars maybe
go further the moons of jupiter and
everything i think that's a very
exciting future
i am amazed at how few people have a
belief system
what do they actually believe in
i and and yeah it's okay to offend you
guys
90 of you will do what's expected of you
as opposed to what you want to do and
you know i even when i come to an event
like this say why am i here
why would i even bother to take an hour
of my valuable time
no it's true i i have to have a purpose
my goal is very simple if i can convert
one of you
there's probably 400 500 people here if
i can convert one of you to follow your
belief and have the guts to follow your
belief
i'll have i'll think of the hour as well
spent
right so i always say what am i trying
to do and why
i don't speak because somebody
you know will write nice things about it
i always sort of have a purpose but i
have a belief system
and most people even successful
companies and have big beef with fortune
500 ceos i can talk about
there's very little leadership there
don't have an internal compass of what
they believe in
it's what do others expect you know when
i graduated
i went into entrepreneurship nobody went
into entrepreneurship out of the
business school
and people said why wouldn't you work
for goldman or mckinsey and i said why
would you
like i couldn't fathom why you would
want to
do that job right uh
i still can't by the way
uh for those of you going to those
places
i'm sure there's plenty i'm probably not
the right person to talk to you
i frankly don't even care to talk to you
all of you others
i i think there's something wrong with
anybody who fundamentally wants to go
work for one of the consultants or the
investment banks today in this part
there's they don't understand how the
world is going to work in the future
but my point again is have a belief
system
follow that compass and i'm overstating
it a bit so
there may be some hope for those of you
going there
but it's only a little bit of an
exaggeration
let me go back to this issue of fortune
500 ceos
i've talked to many over the years
if a new york times writer writes an
article
they want to change their strategy they
want to respond
how silly is that that some english
major who's never had a business job
can determine the strategy of a fortune
500 company
why because they care about what's
written not what their belief system is
do you know what elon musk would say to
that writer go get a real job
right what jeff bezos would say
that's leadership having a belief system
knowing what's driving you to do what
you do
not you're fitting in to do career
enhancement
or making it look good to somebody else
whether it's to your friends or to your
boss or to
shareholders and frankly
you look at all the companies that are
languishing in the valley the older
companies
they generally don't have a belief
system they're generally trying to meet
some quarterly target
without saying here's how we will be
different
and here's how we'll do it apple did
languish for 10 15 years and then steve
jobs came in with a point of view
and created the most valuable company in
the world he did
irrational things if you go back to
january of 2007
january one everybody is saying nobody
wants a phone without a keyboard
nobody wants a phone that costs 6.99 i
can go on with the litany
those were all english majors writing
articles i have this beef against
english majors
not all english majors are bad but the
majority of them
at stanford are undirected and don't
have a goal or a purpose
sorry uh and that's not to say
among them there isn't 20 that are
really good
they just didn't get the right guidance
and ended up in the wrong place
i like purposeful education you have no
idea how you all see things differently
that there's a thinking spectrum
some people are creative and not
reliable some people are reliable not
creative and as you start to
give people a personality tests like
myers-briggs or
the big five or different personality
tests you start to learn how people see
things differently and then when you
see them differently and you and that
screen
pops up where ever rather than just
seeing how you see it
you go above that and you're seeing that
everybody is seeing things differently
it changes how you see things because it
starts to make you think
um how do i know i'm not the wrong one
in other words as you go above it and
you look down on all those different
ways of seeing you start to think
how do i know i'm not the wrong one and
how do i collectively see
and you see in a color range it's like
seeing a different color range or going
from two dimensions to three dimensions
all of a sudden you see the full
spectrum of seeing things
and then you go to the higher level we
have systems that go
through the computers that go the higher
level that say then
how do we weigh all those ways of seeing
to make the best decisions
so not so you don't get so attached to
your opinions
i think the greatest tragedy of mankind
is people holding on to wrong opinions
that could so easily be rectified and
that's doing them hard because they're
making wrong decisions
so how do you collectively do that well
the answer is by everybody seeing
everything
and seeing how others see they begin to
gain those perspectives they also get
to get an appreciation for the other way
of seeing
it used to be that everybody would drive
each other crazy you you your
brain works in one way my brain works in
another maybe i see big picture
you see detail right maybe i'm creative
you're reliable
we drive each other crazy when you start
to realize that people are actually
seeing in those ways and that's a valid
way of seeing and that i need
you and you need me and how to put
together the team
as you're asking about it gives you the
evidence base it's okay
to be different everyone has a gift
everyone
can contribute if they're empowered
and so that's the secret have a society
have institutions have people that
empower
others that enable them to
find their gift turn it into valued
skills and then
apply it in a way that enables them to
succeed by contributing to others
and see how simple this is yeah and
i mean the problem is you need a society
that is relatively based on
the principles of equal rights and
mutual benefit where people succeed by
assisting each other
and everyone has the opportunity to
realize their potential
now that's utopian there's no society
that's been
perfect at that but even ones through
history
that have had a small degree of that
then
what these people can do that no one
suspected could do anything have done
extraordinary things
and change societies and so that's what
we try to do
is go find those people to solve a
problem to eliminate an injustice
and then back them and combine our
capabilities with theirs
to enable them to do even more to help
even more people
what i call this is applying the
principles
of human progress this involves
three different things it because it
requires believing in yourself
believing in other people empowering
them
from the bottom up having them realize
that no one's good at everything
we're all just good at a few things so
we need to partner
with people who have complementary
capabilities
so this gets to frederick douglass's
philosophy that made him such a great
social entrepreneur to unite with
anybody to do right
and no one to do wrong so those are some
of our guidelines
but as i say then the starting point in
all this
is to recognize that everybody can
participate in this
everybody can contribute and succeed if
you're a closed system
you close yourself off from the rest of
the world you try to do everything
yourself
and you're going to fall behind you
probably
die right quickly and that's true for an
organization
and that's true for society so what does
that tell us
it tells us things about immigration
tells us things about free speech and
open
inquiry it tells us about trade it
relates to ricardo's law of comparative
advantage division of labor
comparative advantage when that started
to be allowed
practice rather than everybody having to
do everything themselves
that's when prosperity started to take
off and poverty started to decline in
the 18th century
one of the things that i'd been through
as a student was some leadership
training and one of the things they
taught us was to have
uh to not be afraid of failure and and
instead have the goal to fail a lot
quickly and then eventually he'll
succeed and i sort of took this to heart
and they also had a slogan called
healthy disregard for the impossible
and they actually made you write down
sort of the things you would do that
were kind of impossible but you thought
you might really accomplish
and that's really stuck with me and in
everything that i've tried to do
and i think it was very very close that
we wouldn't have started
the company and i think there are many
of you out there in sort of similar
situations
you know do you want to take a little
bit more risk uh do you want to try
something out and
you know even if you don't succeed we
actually tried many things that didn't
work
you know google happened to work pretty
well but there are many things that we
did that didn't
but we don't worry about those right
because we we tried many things
so i just encourage you to take a little
more risk
in life and i think uh if you do it
often enough they will really pay off
honestly my personality has changed much
since i was five years old
uh i think as i explained to the kids
just a little while ago
uh probably the single most
important aspect of my personality and
as far as determining my success
has been my uh my questioning of
conventional wisdom
my doubting of experts just because
they're experts
and questioning of authority and while
that can be very
very painful in terms of your
relationship with your parents and your
relationship with your teachers
it's enormously useful in life you know
there's there's no
we live in a day and age where you can
start anything do anything and
you you shouldn't put limits on yourself
i think everybody's here because they
don't believe there are limits on
themselves
and that they can get out there and do
anything and i like to point to myself
look if i can do it there's a lot more
people out there that can do it and you
guys should never let anything hold you
back
no one cares whether you live or die
that's what that mentality could rose at
i'm gonna get it or i'm gonna die trying
if i don't try what am i doing what kind
of life am i saving like these things is
wicked in these mean streets none of my
friends
speak we are trying to win we are trying
to win and a lot of times we bumping
heads because we all trying to get out
that's like the crabs in the barrel
mentality
you know that we have because everyone's
trying to survive and they
trying to survive at any cost you have
to look at that you got to look at the
environments and places we live in
and how things are set up and how things
are structured and how we're always the
last on the totem pole even
from our school and to our roads to you
know everything that would that
all the obstacles that's placed in front
of us even our living conditions
and broke is a great motivator have 26
floors and there's a ton of them
right these low-income houses and
everything is messed up there
so living that's like living dormant
if this if this is like this what i have
to live for
then i'm going to take the chance to get
more it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter what happens to me can
you walk through the 10x rule like i
know you sort of touched on points but
like just high level just because some
people
may not know like you're known as the
10x guy but what is a 10x
rule at its core yeah well the 10x rule
first of all the 10x rule is not an idea
it's a way of life
and and people that go 10x are massive
action people and and the premise of the
book is there's four levels of action
there's you see you don't do anything
you retreat you do average
or you go 10x now the first three the
first three
we everybody knows somebody who does
nothing that you call them lazy
actually it's impossible to do nothing
but but just for conversation we'll say
a person does nothing we know that's not
gonna work going
retreating if you retreat your entire
lifetime
it's going to be very painful retreating
by the way is actually
takes more energy than just normal
activity just
the guys that get up every day and go to
work every day going backwards making a
decision to do something and not doing
it is
very painful a lot of wear and tear
going backwards
the third the third one is the most
damaging of all three
which is normal levels of activity the
acceptable
the average the the middle class the
norm
because you get lost these people get
lost they work every day they show up
every day they dig ditches every day
they do a good job every day they're
loyal every day
but they never get rewarded ever uh
number three is the story of my whole
life
that's where i operated the most of my
life most people normal levels of
activity
maybe just above normal just enough to
shine a little bit but dude i never went
for it
and and and so the 10x rule is like okay
how do i
really take some risk here how do i
really put myself out there
so the middle class of america is
basically
laid up on number three being convinced
to go to number two
and then end up with basically they'll
end up with number one
and how do you suggest somebody takes
that
move from three to four yeah so you what
you would what you would do is you
you need to understand that number three
is is the
the biggest disaster that we have it's
where
all wealth is created on the backs of
number three
uh the the the wealthy the wealthy
and this will happen again we'll come
out of this
this virus thing people will go back to
consuming again
and they'll go back to debt they'll go
back to borrowing money to buy things
they don't even need to impress people
they don't even know
because they're unsure about who they
are and where they're going
and so the the middle the middle of the
the spine of america the spine the
middle class of india when it develops
the middle class of china will fund the
wealthy
and because they do the normal things
the wealth wealthy do not do normal
things they do completely
you know they do they don't they don't
save money wealthy people don't save
money they invest money
wealthy people don't spend time or
manage time they they
they take money that's useless they know
it's useless
and they buy i'ma get a thousand
employees
and then everybody's like well you know
that guy never works he hired 1 000
people to do work
this is an old story by the way you can
go back to the king tut
okay i mean it's it's it's not a new
story it's like how do you get wealthy
well you commit to massive action how do
you do massive action
you only have 40 hours a week or 80 or
100.
uh elon musk says hey man 100 hours he
works 100 hours a week he
he does the video about the 100 hours
he's like look if i do 100 and you do 40
i win
he's a smart dude too by the way real
smart guy but he's nobody without the
risk
without the big think and without the
massive action you need things that pull
you forward
once you have your coach once you have
your big dreams once you have your
schedule of exactly what you need to be
doing every day
you need little things that can pull you
forward so you're staying busy
busy in inaction in actions
moving forward things pulling me not
pushing me
things that are pulling me forward okay
i got a date as soon as this is done
today i gotta go do this at ten o'clock
i did i get done with that i got
something at 11 30. i need events
pulling me forward
that could be an event unit you're going
to it could be a conference you're going
to it could be a meeting you're going to
a charity event
have things that are pulling you forward
so that you're accomplishing every day
so that you're proud of yourself
respectful of yourself you're loving
yourself you're feeling good about
yourself
i was insecure before the event
thinking the night before you know
there's no way
all these people aren't going to show up
this place is going to be half empty oh
biggest fear i have that's got to be if
you're walking down the stage and seeing
crickets
nobody's in the room or or
you start and everybody starts leaving
oh you walk it out people start walking
out like this is
two biggest fears i have
so that that was scary all the way up to
the night of the event like i was
terrified
you know and you know fearful like
they're not going to show up that then
even even once we did that we have a
room a third the size of last year
i have worried every day since
the last event whether this one will
work really
yeah why i don't know man i know how
hard they are
yeah it's hard to get people to show up
and i just
even when we're sold out well i'll keep
pushing
i keep selling yeah because i don't
trust the numbers i don't
trust that people will show up that's
the 10x rule
the 10x rule says look you don't stop
when you get there
you keep pushing and that way the place
will be full
he took that 45 caliber and jammed it in
my face cracked me
right here in the forehead this guy had
to be this big
hovered over me with a gun in my face
and when he did my reaction was to hit
him with the plate in the face
thing breaks and he becomes like
a monster blood's coming down every wall
in this apartment
in this room and the ceiling has blood
on it
this was the exclamation mark on where
my life had gone from being a good kid
to this far from dying i spent three
days in the hospital
and i'm like i'm done no more drugs i'm
done using drugs okay
guess what happens i'm using drugs 15
minutes later
10 times a day in the hospital my mom
says to me you're no longer welcome to
my home you're no longer welcome in my
business
i don't want to see you anymore 24 hours
later i was in a treatment center
because my mom had the courage to say
enough is enough i'm done
i go to this treatment center i'm there
30 days for the first 30 days in seven
eight nine years i don't use drugs
and before i leave the counselor grabs
me and the counselor says to me look
dude i'll see you back here
probably you know if you don't die i'll
see you back here and i'm like what are
you talking about dude i'm not coming
back here and he's like oh no you're
coming back
all you're ever going to be is a drug
addict you need to give up all the ideas
of writing books
speaking to audiences being rich i
always wanted to be rich i wanted
financially to be rich my whole life i
wanted to be my dad i wanted to be the
guy that could take care of his family
they said you need to give up all those
ideas and settle for one thing
not using drugs again 25 years old moved
back into my mom's house
tell my mom let me live back in the
house i'm coming back i'm not using
drugs and i'm going to rebuild my
life from that day on 25 i made some
commitments number one was
i cannot afford free time every time i
had free time i got in trouble
so i knew i had to one eliminate the old
bad friends
two i had to keep all free time busy
and i said what are you good at grant
and and i'm like what are you good at
what are you really good at and i'm like
i'm good at going all the way
because even with the drugs i was an all
the way kind of guy right i need to 10x
everything like 10 was that number my
dad died when i was 10.
i was using drugs 10 times a day i was
trying to quit 10 times a day i'm like
you got to start liking something man
and more importantly you got to get good
at something so i said i'm going to take
the job that i don't
like and i'm going to get great at it it
was a sales job that i hated
every day i would go to work
early i'd stay late okay i was doing 10
hour days
at least 10 hours if i needed to make
one call
i would make 10. if i needed to see one
customer if i thought i need to see one
customer i would fill it up with 10
customers
whatever i thought i needed to do i
literally
took this drug problem and poured this
obsession
with destruction into an obsession
with i'm gonna just ten times everything
keep myself busy
i studied everything i became a fanatic
some therapist some psychiatrist is
gonna say oh this dude this dude's got
a.d.d
i've already been told that please i've
had every label
that the psychs put in books i've been
labeled that
okay look i never had any of those
problems i had potential that was
being unused so i wake up early i get a
workout in and i get to the office
when i get to the office a calendar is
laid out and i need to see
every 30 minutes something filled in
that calendar the counselor back in the
treatment center said to me
dude aren't you worried about because
he's seen my success now and he's like
aren't you worried about burning out i'm
like dude you're the burnout bro
you're the burnout you're the one that
said i was gonna come back you're the
one that said
i would never make it you're the one
that said uh uh don't write books i've
written seven of them man
i'm not worried about burnout i am not a
candle
candles burn out spiritual beings don't
my message to you is that you're not
doing enough
okay if you could do it once or twice
then you can do it 20 times just
multiply
and i hear a lot of people say when is
enough enough
those of you who ask that question when
is enough enough maybe you haven't have
enough
had enough failures because if you get
disappointed and disgusted enough with
your life
you will not ask when is enough success
enough
i want to give people permission to be
complete
addicts junkies obsessed maniacs
all in freakazoids that do everything
10 times more than you think you need to
i want to see
how hot can i burn okay how far can i go
how much light can i bring the world how
much positive truth message can i
bring this planet how much more can i do
you must think in terms of 10x
you have to think about expansion
exponential
moves so whether it's 10 000 you have
100 000 you have i'm just talking about
money for a second
or whether it's a 10 million dollars
okay maybe it's a charity that you
raised last year you raised a hundred
thousand for make-a-wish okay
and you're like what are we going to do
this year we got to beat we got to beat
last year
we got to beat it yeah but why don't you
not beat it why don't you stomp it in
the ground and act like it was dumb
that's exactly what i've done with my
businesses for the last seven or eight
years the first 20 years i thought small
i acted small i tried to preserve my
position
okay number one you have to give up your
position you must give up your position
number two the second thing i've done
over the last seven or eight years is
exponentially just grown grown all my
brands
my name my recognition uh the businesses
the top line
i have been willing to put money at risk
to 10x my business how do you go from
being a personal assistant making a
hundred and
whatever 100 000 a year let's say i
don't know what kayla makes
okay it's below my pay grade i don't
need to know that how does she start
thinking about how do i turn this into a
million dollars
regardless of whether she's 20 or her
position or wherever
how can she multiply time how can she
multiply money how can she multiply
opportunity go big
or go go bigger get rid of this go home
option
okay i don't know who gave you guys this
option that's not an option
i can't go home i have to go bigger and
by the way
i'm not interested in home i'm
interested in prosperity and paradise
i'd like to never go home
we did nine countries in in 34 days
i got to tell you we didn't even want to
come home i don't know where i am most
of the time
i don't know what day it is i don't know
what time it is i just know hey i got
this moment man right here let's make
the most of this moment
i don't know if i live once or twice
okay i know this i need to take
advantage of what i have right now and i
can't do that by myself i don't want to
be by myself
we don't want to just be the four of us
i don't want to just be me
elena sabrina and scarlett i want to i
want i want a nation i don't want a
tribe
i don't want to tribe i want friends all
over the world i want sabrina and
scarlet when they grow up
and they go to to switzerland they have
friends
in switzerland okay if the world falls
apart
we have friends in oklahoma or in
central
or maybe i gotta go to south america for
a while maybe i gotta go hang out
okay i will not fulfill my mission my
mission is to help people
i will be known for the people i help
not the money i made nobody's going to
remember nobody's going to say 50 years
from now 100 years from now
oh grant cardone had a great jet nobody
nobody will ever mention that
my books might live on okay my audio
will
guarantee you my audio will live long
after i'm dead
but your memories with me you using our
technologies okay
will live on forever you live on through
other people walt disney did it
he lives on today man okay
build a legacy folks build a legacy put
yourself out there okay
10x your lives 10x the lives of the
people around you
give more than you take give more than
you take
give more than you take and i promise
you you will get more than you ever
dreamed of
i was 50 52 years old and i had a
problem
i was depressed i wasn't satisfied i was
hungry but didn't know what to do
i had businesses i had money i had a
whole bunch of stuff but i'm like dude
what am i doing now
i'm bickering with elena we had our kids
we had the first two kids and we're like
okay we got a kid i'm being a parent now
okay i'm being a married guy right i'm
being a businessman and i'm unhappy
and then i start asking people what's
wrong man what's wrong what's wrong with
me man something wrong with me
something wrong with me oh yeah and as
soon as you say is something wrong with
me
everybody's got an opinion oh yeah man
man you got a disease man you got a
problem you got issues man you work too
much
you're a work addict you you you you're
insecure
your daddy died your daddy died and left
a hole in you
left a hole in me i can't go on a
vacation
i want to do something man
[Music]
doing less has never solved my problems
doing less moderation has never solved a
problem for me
the problem that i've had in my life
okay was not my marriage
it's not okay i'm not a bad parent i
wasn't helping enough people
you should be up here you should be
dropping out of the ceiling
you should be helping more people the
world you live in today
the cnbc and the cnn and the netflix
be happy just be happy
be satisfied with what you have there's
no push man
there's nobody pushing you how about
this you can do more
how many of you can do more oh my god
if that's all you got how many of you
can do more
well god damn if you know you can do
more if you know you can do more
then you have to do more if you know you
can help
if you know you can make a difference if
you don't
you're going to have this freaking big
big hole inside no
no amount of money can fill this thing
up
so fill it up the middle class adds and
subtracts
and and clearly the middle class never
figured out
how to do what the super wealthy do like
it's almost like
hundreds of millions of people in
america stop math at adding and
subtracting and never got to the
multiplication part
because the super wealthy are
multipliers oh by the way time
energy and money they multiply all of
them they're like like i have time i
want to make more time you learn how to
add you learned how to subtract but
that's not what the ross challenge did
that's not what the rockefellers did
that's not what the duponts did
they multipliers
they're multipliers this by the way 10x
is
a gateway drug to the illuminati
i'm telling you right now the 10x was
basically a secret
kind of passage for all of you that want
the new world order
for all of you interested in the
invisible rich for the masons out there
that you're like i know there's 13
families i know
there's a deal with the federal reserve
i know there's world monarchs don't you
know that 10x the 10x rule
don't you guys know the 10x rule is
actually the front door
to this secret society to the invisible
rich
i mean who does not think that i'm being
basically primed for the
nwo
i'm just i'm just saying it before you
guys start accusing me
of being part of the club i thought i
would just say it about myself
and then therefore take away the energy
of the whole situation
let's talk to the next caller okay
i know one thing you ain't getting in
that club if that club exists you ain't
getting in it
because you bought a house you're not
going to get in it because you got a
401k
everybody agree with that you're not
going to get in it because you had a
college degree
okay if you want to put little baby goat
blood
on your chest on a friday night
you're gonna have to have some net worth
and the only way to get some net worth
is to learn how to multiply time
energy and money if you want freedom by
the way
and i look i condemn these people if
there's 13 families that control the
whole world
i want to meet them i got to tell you i
want to meet him back
you can do more you can do more than you
ever imagined
i was broke at 25 years old
broke okay every two years i get one of
these cars
the people at rolls-royce like i want to
send you another one of those cars okay
how you want it how you want to dress
what color you want it
like it's crazy it's crazy the life i'm
living right now
we did a we did a conference it was 10
000 people in the room and another 10
000 people online
all of them paid to be there i remember
when
i couldn't get two people to show up at
a party in high school
because i was so disliked you can do
more than you think you can
it's my message to you today you will
live longer than you think
i promise you okay you can do
more than you think you can now i've got
some special bonus clips that i think
you're gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the
billionaire mindset
question of the day i wanna know what
was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and your plan of action
for the next week also if you've already
got your billionaire mindset companion
pdf calendar
get ready for another amazing video
tomorrow or if you don't have it yet you
can get it for free in the first line of
the description below and if you're
enjoying this billionaire mindset series
give me a hashtag
billionaire mindset in the comments
below so i can celebrate you
what's the difference between you and
jack ma you both have crazy dreams
you both started with the odds stacked
against you you both
started with very little resources so
what's the difference
the difference is that jack kept
believing in his dreams and his ideas
when most people quit and give up so i
actually think you should be on a
mission for life i'm not a big believer
in in five year goals or ten year goals
i think they can help but i think
if you have a five or ten year goal
you're actually thinking small because
you can't predict where you're gonna be
in five or ten years just like the
person you were five or ten years ago
could not have designed the life for
where you're at right now not if you're
growing
because the world's changing too quickly
and you're growing and evolving so the
ideas and goals that you had five years
ago may not even be relevant anymore
but the mission stays the same my
mission is believe
right your purpose comes from your pain
so my my mission is believe i want to
support entrepreneurs
because i struggle so much as an
entrepreneur and i think it's the
world's biggest problem i think the
world's biggest problem is people don't
believe in themselves enough
i think any other problem that you come
up with should have already been solved
by now
but the person who could solve that
cancer you know the woman who should
have solved cancer
is an account manager at mcdonald's
because she never won she never tried
going to medical school or two she
did but she didn't believe in herself
enough to chase it down because
everybody around there was telling her
that she's crazy you should be crazy
you're doing something that's never been
done before you're on a mission
right and so no matter how many people i
touch with with all of my content all of
my channels every video that i'm making
every speaking gig
every city that i go to no matter how
many people i touch
it's not going to be enough i think
that's great
i think you should have a mission so big
that you're never going to actually
accomplish it i think of ted turner's
father
who when he made a certain amount of
money became a millionaire or whatever
the number was
he killed himself because he hit his
goal
and and hitting your goal is actually
sad and so ted turner
decided that i'm going to set a goal so
big that i can never hit it and that's
way more where i'm aligned i think you
should have a mission something so big
that you can never hit it some people
think of that as
well it's too it's too big and so i even
try
and i think of that that starfish
example of the kids at the beach with
the starfish
and there's like a million starfish on
the beach and she's throwing the
starfish back in the water so they can
live
and the guy walks by and says what are
you doing you can't save all the
starfish
and she says i know but i can save that
one and this one
and that one right and so each person
that you helped each step
you take is is beneficial it's helpful
you never want to actually hit the goal
but you wake up every day working your
face off to try to hit the goal
right to hit that mission and so that's
belief for me and i i desperately hope
that you find it for you
so how do you keep believing your dreams
i'm gonna give you a three-step process
that i think will help
number one is make big decisions with
your heart so big decisions with the
heart small ones with the head
at the beginning when you're trying to
decide what to do your head and your
heart often will
will fight they'll conflict they won't
be aligned because your head only
understands a world that currently
exists
it's safe it's practical it's logical
and knows what currently exists
where your heart can create something
brand new your heart can imagine
something that's never
existed before and so they clash at the
beginning
right your heart wants to go do this
thing but you don't know how it's going
to work out because it doesn't make
sense
because nobody's done it before and
especially someone who looks like you
with your resources and your education
your background and your connections and
your financial situation
nobody like you has ever done it before
that's what your head's saying and so
this is big fight
you need to take control of the
situation you need to get them aligned
by saying this
is what i'm doing right big decisions
with the heart
and then your head saying oh he's
serious
she's serious okay i better help because
i don't want to die
and now your head starts working with
you now your head starts helping you
figure out how to actually go off and
accomplish it you're using your thinking
side to help you accomplish your mission
but at the very beginning it doesn't
make sense and so they'll fight
so the big decisions with the heart and
then the small ones with your head to
help you figure out how to actually do
it
step number two is daily momentum the
biggest thing that you are missing is
momentum you're a genius you have
michael jordan level talent you can save
the world you've got a big ambitious
crazy mission that you're on i love it
it's amazing that's why you're here
that's why you're an entrepreneur let's
go
right i'm excited pretty easily about
entrepreneurship
the problem is you don't have momentum
there's no momentum
nothing's happening enough on a daily
basis and so you need
daily momentum it doesn't matter that
you watch one video like this
and then you're on fire the rest of the
day it has to be every day every single
day you have to build momentum to your
business
too many entrepreneurs they start and
they stop and they start and they stop
and they're starting to stop they never
get anywhere
because they're too busy starting and
stopping and and then you're one of the
worst mom
you didn't create the momentum that's
what's missing every single day
do the thing put it into your morning
routine that makes you feel bold alive
unstoppable confident
and then go out and create momentum that
is your duty your responsibility
your must every single day create
momentum and then step number three is
ask yourself what would the most bold
version of you do
what would the most bold version of you
do just ask that question here's your
mission here's what you're trying to
accomplish you're looking at your
calendar
you're looking at what you want to
accomplish what would the most bold verb
just
eliminate any insecurities eliminate
fears eliminate judgment eliminate the
toxic people for your life just for
this magical you know 18 seconds
and ask yourself what would the most
bold version of me do
and then see what comes back and then
chances are
that's the actual thing that you should
be doing because you know what
you do bold things your biggest problem
is a lack of belief the only thing
that's holding you back
holding me back holding your friends and
family back
is a lack of belief it is the world's
biggest problem
and that's why i created these youtube
channels i've seen the impact
not just on the people around me but
myself firsthand myself
the value of having my own channel in
the work that i do i make it selfishly
for myself so that i learn that i get
better that i grow
that i challenge myself and it's often
hard to see it on a day-to-day basis
you may not feel a lot more confident
have a lot more belief from one day to
the next you might have some big win
you might take on some big challenge and
then you feel good about yourself but
then you fall back down the next day
and you don't see that that's actually a
win because the wind that you had was so
small
the growth that you had was so tiny that
on a day-to-day basis
you can't see it that's the problem but
if you consistently are doing the things
like watching this channel or consuming
a podcast or reading the book or hanging
around people
who are better than you who have more
belief than you who who are growing and
pushing
that inspire you if you're around that
every single day
and you look back on your life you look
back in the past x number of months
you'll see how much you've grown you
just will i've seen it in my own
business go back
and look at my old content i started a
new series on my other channel
where it's old evan versus new evan and
the first video we did was 2016
evan versus 2019 evan and what do you
think and you may not see that big a
difference in me
from last week's video to this week's
video or yesterday's entspresso to
today's entspresso
but when you go back three years so it
doesn't even look like the same person
go back 10 years go back and watch my
first videos
go back and watch the first videos the
content was still good the message was
still good but the delivery
the execution sucked because i didn't
know what i was doing
because i didn't have a lot of belief
and i'm still trying to chase the next
level you know i've grown and believed
but i'm never done
the thing that's holding me back is
still belief it's belief in
the ability to get to the next step
because as you expand your comfort zone
there's still other things that are
outside your comfort zone you don't want
to ever get to the point where you're
not growing where there's not something
outside your comfort zone
but then everything inside becomes easy
right what used to scare you
now is super easy now isn't a problem
anymore and so you can see it in my
growth if you
if you go back ten years ago or five
years ago or three years ago or six
months ago you can see
the growth and progression and i want
that for all of you too how did i do it
it's practice it's repetition but it's
it's it's bringing in
i've got steve jobs in my ear and kanye
west in my ear and elon musk and oprah
winfrey and david goggins in my ear
every day and if you're around that
every single day you can't help but grow
you can't help but grow even if you have
toxic people around you
parents who don't support you friends
who say you're never gonna make it
if you have all this negativity around
you but you've got something
in your environment every single day
that's pushing you forward i guarantee
you you're gonna grow
i think that lack of belief is the
world's biggest problem because i think
everybody has michael jordan level
talent at something
you are michael jordan the best in the
world that's something you are
at something just maybe not the thing
you're doing right now
and that's the problem most people are
doing the wrong thing
whatever you think the world's biggest
problem is pollution
cancer whatever it is i think the woman
who solves cancer
is now working as a manager at some
company and she hates her life instead
of taking a chance on biology and
suddenly become a doctor
because somebody told her that she
couldn't do it or she told herself that
she couldn't do it
she didn't have the belief i think
that's the world's biggest problem if we
allowed everybody to discover their
michael jordan level talents
abilities and then believe in themselves
enough to chase it down
holy cow what a beautiful world that's
going to be and that's why i wake up
every day trying to go and tackle
so how do you create more belief for
yourself i'm going to give you a
three-step process that i think will
help
step number one is create an environment
of excellence
you are a product of your environment
your environment has been perfectly
designed to keep you exactly where you
are
it is now you just maybe haven't done it
with intention that's a problem for most
people
right i've created this environment that
i'm in right now
with intention the people behind me on
the wall they're there for intention
every person tells a story
that reminds me every time i walk into
my office and look at them they may not
mean anything to you
but to me it means a lot having having
this bag of treats i want to eat this
bag of juice right now
it looks so good damn the doritos
right i have it here as a reminder to
myself that i'm stronger than the
doritos and i have it in front of me all
day long there it is
right there damn the doritos what's the
thing that makes you come alive what's
an environment of excellence for you
and yes maybe your ideal is you want to
be at ten thousand dollar a night hotels
and
flying helicopters and this expensive
lifestyle okay great
can't do that yet probably awesome
what's a small version of it
what's a small version of it even if
you've got all this negativity around
you and people and
all this stuff you know hitting you that
says you can't do it
great carve out the space for yourself
carve out that environment of excellence
whether it's in your car
your home your bedroom your office
wherever you're spending time
environment of excellence matters
because what's beautiful about all this
stuff here is you set it up once
i set it up once with intention what
makes me feel believe this
this makes me feel believe i set it up
once with intention
and then every day i walk in and i feel
believe
looking at this stuff that's what you
need to do as well create an environment
of excellence for yourself
step number two is 254s so in almost
every video i talked about
a 254. what is it for those of you who
are on the 254s it's been amazing seeing
the growth
the idea basically is every day for 254
days i send you a video that is free
around certain topics we've done it for
writers we've done it for self-love
we've known for confidence we've done it
from women entrepreneurs we've done it
for
lots of different categories ultimately
i want to have a thousand different ones
of these
and what happens is if you're a writer
you sign up for the writer's wisdom
every day you get a video from a writer
with an inspirational message
and it forces you to have that writer
and that knowledge and that motivation
and that mindset
seep into you every day just watch the
video why 254 days because it takes
between 18 and 254 days of consecutive
action to build a habit
and so even if you're the slowest
learner of all time i'm still with you
every step of the way
now you don't have to do mine create
your own if you do something
consistently every day you will find
that you change and that that's not just
mindset that's not just belief systems
that's anything right if you work out
every day
for 254 days you're going to see some
results right
hopefully a lot sooner but what's the
belief that you want you want to have
more confidence do you want to believe
in yourself more like what's the thing
that you want
desperately in your life and then create
your own 254
if i haven't done one for you create
your own and surround yourself with it
every single day and it's this little
micro injection it's a little micro
injection
i'm doing my allergy shots right now
i've had seasonal allergies for
i don't know a long time and the doctor
said hey we can do these little
injections every week
so that over time you go for almost a
year
and then you're not allergic to the
thing anymore so i'm allergic to grass
and trees and they inject
a little bit of grass and trees into my
bloodstream every week
and they strengthen the dose every week
and so now when i'm going out it doesn't
impact me as much
right and after year you're good and so
that same approach
applies to mindset and belief systems
and personal development although you're
never good you're always continuing to
grow
but that little bit of injection every
single day every single day every single
day
again you won't see major growth from
day to day but when you look back
you see a huge growth over x number of
weeks or months
and that leads me to step number three
which is a six month test
i would try to find somebody who you
haven't seen in six months
or make a video of yourself now and then
make another one in six months and look
back so that you can see the growth
because
we we massively underestimate what we
can do in a long period of time
and overestimate what we can do in a
short amount of time so you'll you'll
work like crazy one day and try to get
so much done
and then if you then slack off for the
rest of the week you're not gonna have
major growth but if every single day
you're doing the thing
you'll notice that you have major growth
and so find someone who you haven't
seen for six months if you've been going
on this journey and you've been learning
and investing in yourself and
surrounding yourself with content
videos and books and podcasts that that
lift you up to make you feel better
every single day find someone you
haven't seen in six months
and then talk to them and see if they
tell you that you've changed
or record yourself on camera right now
right now make a video to yourself
and then do something every day for six
months
and then come back and watch that video
again and see how much you've grown
it'll be mind-blowing it'll be
mind-blowing
how much you can grow we're just not
giving enough credit
to the daily tiny little incremental
changes that we're making and so take
the six-month test
and impress yourself you go as far as
you believe you can go
when the people around you say you're
crazy when you're putting in massive
effort but you're not getting the
results
where you sit alone and wonder did you
just make the biggest mistake
of your life by starting this business
that
is the time when most people quit and
you need to believe more
because if you love this thing if you
know that it's going to impact people
and you give up too soon you will regret
for the rest of your life
knowing that you were capable of more
and you just quit on it a little too
early
so i look at my new book as an example i
did my tour across america met with
entrepreneurs
all across america and found that people
were struggling with the same thing they
want to know how do i find
what my purpose is and turn it into a
lucrative business
every city that i went to even though
that was not the topic i was covering
it came up over and over and over and
over again 23 different cities
and so i thought i'm going to write a
book on this this is going to be my next
book i'm going to take people through
the process
because my process works and it helps
people live in in 10 15 minutes and
they're getting
they're getting new ideas and and
results and here we go like
they understand what path they need to
take finally they have clarity on what
to do next
and so i told my agent and my lit agent
like this is the next book i want to
write
we told publishers this is the next book
i'm going to write and from the start
it's been this big
pull it's been it's been fighting it's
we don't like the title
we don't like the concept no we're not
going to publish it no we're not going
to publish it and
i want to do it by january because i
want to do my next tour across
the rest of the united states east coast
texas mexico i want to do my next tour
so i want to have my book in stores
by that time and it's been this rough
slog
where if i didn't believe in myself that
this was so important with the people
who are looking at it saying no we don't
like this concept
nah it's been written before now this
method we don't believe in
it's easy to quit it's easy to give up
it's easy to say forget it
i just know that it's gonna work i know
that the process helps people
i've seen it with my eyes across 23
cities
over 90 days i wrote the draft of the
book and i gave it to
some beta readers and the number one
piece of advice from people who've read
both my books the year one word and then
this like this is
this is the better book this is the best
book you've written so far
including my self-published ones and so
what do i do i've got these people who
are my audience who love it and then
these people who aren't my audience but
who make decisions saying now we don't
believe in it
i'm not gonna quit i gotta keep going
i gotta do my tour there better be some
crazy good reason for me not to do my
tour
right even if i have to self-publish it
no i'm pretty close to making my deal
making it all happen and
and getting timelines and all that but
we don't have a signed contract yet and
anything can happen
we're pushing the timelines because i'm
pushing the timelines because otherwise
this thing could drag on forever
when you have an idea that you love that
you know can have a huge impact
that's just taking longer than you hoped
it would when people are telling you
that
it's crazy and that it's stupid and that
who are you to go up and do this thing
if you love it you have to double down
on it you have to go in on it
you have to be open to getting help
but if that door closes you try to find
another one and that's the story of
every successful person
you're trying to do something different
95 of the world
wakes up and drives to a job that they
hate i believe that you have michael
jordan level talent at something that
you are a genius
you are the best the best at something
most people either one have no idea what
that thing is
or two they have found it but they don't
have the courage or belief
to go chase it down either way the path
is through
you need to find the thing that you are
a genius at that you have michael jordan
level talent
at and live it every single day if you
want to live your life
instead of regret your life this is why
i do what i do
i want people to believe in themselves
more i look at people and i
i see this person who hates their life
and
and then there's so much talent you have
so much talent you want to serve you
want to help others you want to make an
impact you want to make a difference
everybody does it's a human condition
and you know you're capable of more than
what you're doing right now
you know it and this is what i want to
help bring out in people it's why i make
the videos that i do and write the books
and do the
my speaking all of it because i want to
pull that out i want you to
suck on whatever energy that i can give
you so that you then realize
maybe i am a genius maybe i do have
great ideas maybe maybe what i have
could actually change the world maybe i
need to stop doing the thing that i'm
doing maybe
maybe there is some hope right that's
what i want to try to inject into people
and so i have an eight-step process that
i'll take you through super quick
that if you are are struggling with
belief if you are struggling thinking
that
i don't know if i'm a genius at
something this process will help you
it'll help you believe in your big ideas
it'll help you believe in your
capabilities and it'll help you go off
and actually make an impact
let's dive in number one is find your
purpose you got to find out what the
thing is that you're here to do right i
have my who i have process
figure out who what your one word is
your most important core value
two your purpose comes from your pain
the thing that you struggle the most
with is the thing that you want to help
other people through
whatever you struggled the most with the
the worst moment in your life whatever
you remember that is
your purpose for life will be helping
other people who are currently going
through that pain
and then through the how how you got out
of it how you got through it
will be a recipe to teach other people
you'll be able to as you take your steps
on the staircase up
lift other people up to join you on that
step so step number one in believing in
yourself more is figuring out what is
your purpose
step number two is going from idea to
action you have great ideas
you have great ideas of problems you
judge your ideas you come with a great
idea in the shower
and then you spend the rest of the day
thinking about it researching planning
it judging it saying i can't do that or
how's that gonna work and then you wake
up tomorrow a different person
the faster you go from idea to action
will that will dictate your entire
future
it'll change the entire trajectory of
your life the faster you go from idea to
action stop
judging your ideas you get an idea you
go for it you do it the two percent
difference stop planning to get 100
and just take action on the first two
percent you'll never figure out the
whole plan
by sitting on your couch you won't you
figure it out by doing idea to action
train yourself you get an idea you do
something about it because your ideas
list
is never going to get any shorter it's
growing every day you're a genius you
come with great ideas that's not enough
you got to do something about them
and so immediate action you get an idea
boom the two percent difference what's
one thing that you can do that'll take
you two percent of the way
to making some momentum on this idea the
smallest simplest dumbest
stupidest thing that you can do right
now today on your idea
idea to action step three is model
success
have people around you who inspire you
who lift you up who show you that as
possible
i love my youtube channel for for myself
i need it for me
i surround myself with steve jobs and
kanye and oprah and all these people for
me for myself
i want it i want to be around successful
people because what it does it rubs off
on you
it rubs off it's like they're sprinkling
little steve jobs pixie dust on you
it rubs off it shows you two things one
that it's possible because all of your
heroes
they started with less than what you
currently have right now you feel like
it's overwhelming and impossible in your
environment
and it's just it's never going to happen
whoever you look up to
whoever your heroes are they had it
worse than you have it right now
they struggled through worse than what
you're struggling to right now and so
they could do it you can't too
there's no excuse if you're surrounded
by people who just tell you oh take it
easy take it slow
yeah of course of course you can't do it
because you were born at x or because
you come from this community
of course yeah just you're never gonna
make it right
screw the president screw the system
right most people that's how they live
but other people they've won they've
done it despite coming from worse
circumstances than you
you have no excuse and so when you
surround yourself with those people
who are often winning who who look like
you came from the same background as you
struggle with the same things as you or
worse
it's motivating it gives you hope that's
possible you need to be around success
you need to model it and and it gives
you the hope and it also gives you
strategies
bill gates saved my company i've never
met him yet
but but what he did give me hope that
what i wanted to do was possible with my
software company
and how he got through was a recipe for
me i
modeled how he got through it and that
started to take my company forward
so step three and believe in yourself
more is you need to model success
step four is create an environment of
excellence an environment of excellence
what in your environment makes you feel
excellent
it starts with you how you carry
yourself i love wearing this right like
i wear this not just for
the camera i like it like i feel like
batman putting on my outfit putting on
my superhero cape
right when i wear this how do you want
to express yourself
from the clothes you wear from from your
haircuts from the jewelry you put on
how do you gonna express yourself that
is excellent
that reminds you of who you are and what
you're capable of
next you go out to your physical
environment so these people are all
behind me for a reason i walk into this
office
and without even having to think about
it i've got these people staring me down
reminding me to be excellent to go chase
down my dreams right
what's on your what's on your cell phone
background what's on your computer
background
right these are things that you set up
once in your environment and then it
triggers you i call them play bigger
triggers
they're there for you every single day
to remind you right if i'm if i'm
feeling low if i feel like i don't
believe in myself enough i got my
parents right here telling me
hey evan you're just really carmichael
believe in yourself more
if i'm struggling with my vision i got
steve job i got steve jobs staring me
down right here
right i'm my this is my computer i'm
looking here i got this guy
eyes on me right now maybe that's too
creepy for you scary for you awesome
design for yourself designed for your
excellence what makes you feel bold
and want to come alive and have that as
a daily part of your routine
step number five is schedule for success
so i just mentioned routines what is
your routine what are you doing on a
daily basis
show me how the actions that you're
doing what's in your calendar
will help you accomplish your goals
right your actions have to map to your
ambitions you say you want this
amazing i love it i'm pumped now show me
your calendar where you're going to do
it
you say you want to have a million
subscribers on youtube amazing you say
you want to sell a million books amazing
you say you want to
have a million dollar business amazing
show me your calendar where are you
spending your time
on making videos on writing books on
building your business like it has to be
in your calendar most people
they don't have it in your calendar and
if you don't have in your calendar it's
never going to get done
and not just business life success you
want to be a successful
husband father mother daughter wife
anything
where's that time put in your calendar
right show me your calendar your
calendar
is your habits and your habits will
dictate your success
and so what you do on a weekly basis in
your calendar and
also how you start your day every day
most people wake up like an accident
most people wake up they hit the snooze
button
which already you're telling yourself
that you you're the kind of person who
doesn't follow through on your goals
and you start responding to other
people's emergencies no
start your day with intention you could
have had the greatest day of all time
yesterday and you wake up today and it's
you're starting over
so what makes you come alive and then
put that into your morning routine
with intention every day so you stop
waking up like an accident you do that
you're gonna believe in yourself more
step number six to believe in yourself
more is manufacturing self-confidence
manufacture self-confidence you do
difficult things you need to teach
yourself
that you do difficult things that when
something is hard you want to do it you
love hard things that when your heart's
beating and you're scared you're nervous
that's a sign you have to go do that
thing
self-confidence self-love self-respect
comes from
following through on the things you say
you're going to do
but it doesn't count until it's
difficult waking up at
x in the morning right you want to wake
up at six in the morning great
when it's easy it doesn't count you
don't feel good about yourself you don't
feel bad it's just it's easy
this one is hard it's when it's hard
right if you if you ran a race against
three-year-olds right and you won
you might post about it say yeah i won
this race but inside you know it's a
fake
you know it's a fake win it doesn't
count but if you get up and run against
hussein bolt he's going to destroy you
but you can feel good that you tried
right are you proud of your effort
you want to manufacture self-confidence
you want more belief are you proud of
yourself today and it's not something
that
that anybody else can give you
should i be proud of myself i don't know
did i do enough reps i don't know
did i did i write enough words for my
book i don't know are you proud of
yourself
i can tell you when i broke my neck on
my tour and i was sitting at the front
for three and a half hours in massive
pain
delivering my presentation i was proud
of myself
even though the quality went down right
i was better when i was being
able to walk around and not have so much
pain i felt like my presentation
delivery was better
but i was more proud of myself for doing
it when it was hard that's how you
manufacture self-confidence that's how
you manufacture self-belief
it's doing it when it's hard it does not
count until it's hard
and that you do difficult things step
number seven to believe in yourself more
is beating negative judgment
if you're doing anything that's
different anything that's outside the
norm guess what
there's a lot of people who love the
norm there's a lot of people who will
say hey
you suck like stop doing this they want
to protect the status quo
because if you go off and win it makes
them look bad it makes them feel bad
about themself
right you you winning makes them feel
bad about themself
and so you're going to have a lot of
people who all they focus on is tearing
other people down
you may even have your parents who who
are giving you advice out of love
but your parents are pilgrims you were
growing up in a different era than they
did
if you're if you're 20 years old right
now your parents at 20 years old the
world is different
the amount of things that a 20 year old
can do right now to build a business to
have success to make a meaningful impact
on the world
is crazy compared to what was available
when your parents are 20 years old
they don't understand the world that you
live in and so their advice
is out of love but they just don't
understand what's possible
and so you get advice that's out of love
that's still negative you'll see it as
negative
and you'll also get hey you'll get
people who watch your videos read your
book and say you
suck that's the worst thing i've ever
seen in my life
but what's the alternative to never
ruffle any feathers to never do anything
bold or big or great
to to live your entire life in fear of
being rejected and fear people laughing
at you
and so you play small your whole life
and then you're 95 you look back and say
i never did anything great i knew it was
capable i never did it
you need to learn to attack judgment you
attack it if you're afraid of
even the possibility of judgment then
you do it it's why i painted my nails a
while back
because i was afraid of people judging
me for having my nails painted
so then i had to do it you have to do it
just to beat it just to eat the judgment
you need to train yourself because if
you want to go off and do some some
amazing big thing
but you can't do something as simple as
painting your nails you've lost you're
so worried
about other people's opinions that
you'll play small forever
and so the next time you feel yourself
worried about somebody else's opinion
then you have to go off and do that
thing
now within your code of ethics right
don't go don't go beat somebody up don't
go
you know mock somebody don't don't do
something against your values
but most of the things that you want to
do you want to do it's for you it's not
against somebody else you want to do it
for you and you're afraid of what the
reaction is going to be
that's the fear that you need to quash
and as soon as you catch it you need to
say
i'm gonna do it i'm gonna i'm gonna beat
that negative judgment i'm gonna feel
that fear
and i'm gonna do it anyway and then step
number eight to getting more belief is
to make an impact
we wanna make an impact making money is
important it has to be money has to be
in your top five
it's just not number one money's not
number one there's not number 100 on
your list either it's got to be in your
top five
but something comes ahead of it and
that's the impact that you want to have
what is the impact how are you going to
do it and then start feeling it start
seeing it start
start appreciating it you know for me
i'm just here in my office talking to
the camera
it's me and the camera alone in a room
but it's going out and being broadcast
and you're watching it right now and i
appreciate that
and i and i remind myself of the work
that i do every day
matters it's touching people and maybe
that's just one person maybe
maybe you help one person today and you
feel the impact of that or maybe it's a
hundred or a thousand or a hundred
thousand however many right
your impact will continue to grow with
time especially entrepreneurs
we want to have a big impact not just
one person at a time
but remembering that that you're here to
do something good
and that your work matters if you woke
up every day and felt like the work that
you do
matters to somebody it's having an
impact on somebody is serving other
people because humans are built to serve
and if you felt like that every single
day man
your life would be dramatically
different if you want to sign up for the
entire billionaire mindset series for
free and get the companion bonus pdf
calendar check the link right there next
to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there